People have a hard time talking about money because
Money is the root of all of our problems
My relationship with the money is I don't like understand money ... (laughs)
Where did my other sock go?
My name is Quinn, I'm 22 years old and I live in San Francisco
I'm a software engineering intern at a small startup
Do you mind telling me how your day started?
I woke up and then... (laughs)
Went in my car to get something and found out that it'd been towed
(laughs)
And how much did that cost?
I got a 90 something dollar discount because it was the first time my car had been towed
and it still came out to almost 600 dollars
So we're starting the day at—
(sighs)... Yeah
Background guy: Minus $600?
(laughs) ... Minus 600
I'm paid $2,000 a week. So for a 40-hour week, that's $50 an hour
So computer science is something I had just dabbled in as a requirement for my math degree and then I just decided to do it
And he's with me as well
I'm Dolly Avenue. I am 23 years old and I live in Los Angeles, California
I make a living using my camera to take pictures
So the great thing about freelancing is you never really know how much you're gonna make
How much do you think you make a month?
Um... Four or five K
So I like C++, but I don't get to work in C++ a lot
What kind of programming do you want to go into?
Probably beta application
Oh gosh, good luck ... (laughs)
I'm missing my keys...
(laughs in relief?)
Could've been bad
Hi! You look cute. Oh my gosh, what is happening?
Getting into the office I probably spend about 30 minutes to an hour just figuring out what I was doing ...
(laughs)
last time I was working
I like where I work a lot right now
Do I love coding?
No, it's too much of how the sausage is made ... (laughs)
Thank you for the tea
So today we were shooting with Brooke who wanted to make a calendar for her boyfriend
Do you have bubbles?
Brooke: Yeah
Nice
This is gonna be fun
Fiit 530 East 8th Street, I'm assuming this way
Such a good friend ... (laughs)
Sweet, thanks.
Aww, it's an intimate space
No straight on
More angled, you and me sitting and stuff. Anyways, yeah be cool
Yeah, just let me know if anything else but let's get it
(laughs)
My favourite thing in the photograph hands down is people
I absolutely love the energy and understanding somebody. I think that's what— what makes me keep creating
Takes so much for someone to be
completely confident and vulnerable
So allowing me into their space and capturing their soul in a sense, I think that's rewarding
These look great and if you smile, smile that way okay
3, 2, 1 go. Smile.
(background chatter)
It's falling on you ... (laughs)
(chatting about engineering)
Anybody else upgrade to X 26. Oh my
Friend: It's working swimmingly
(laughs)
Um.. can I grab a spinach and goat cheese quiche and a matcha latte please
Worker: That'll be $13.00
I think that people problems are more interesting than technical problems
So my favorite part of my day as a software developer is when I got to solve the problem with someone else
so I guess I could be happier if I was just
teaching high school
What's stopping you from pursuing that?
I think it's important that you aim for things you're passionate about, but that need not be grounded in your career
Like I would not want my parents to feel
insecure about my future
After my third semester of college, my dad was diagnosed with multiple myeloma, which is a type of bone marrow cancer
And I'm his only child. So it fell on me to take care of him
Luckily, he came out the other side
There is no way I could value two years in the middle of my life over two years potentially at the end of his
My decision to take care of him was very like logical because that's the type of person I am. That's the way I solve problems
That's okay. Wait, it's fizzing.
(yawns)
Like we're the Kardashians and we're just having somebody. Oh man, ha, he can hear me.
These are gonna look so good
I had a tough life because my parents were incompatible
Emotional abuse, physical abuse on top of that they didn't have an education
they're trying to find a job trying to find a place to live and having children to take care of
Our circumstances put us in situations that weren't ideal
That's how we grew up. And from there we just kind of learned how to survive
I think like with money if you make the effort to change
your mentality and your lifestyle that goes even with your career and if you're open-minded to change like
You can pursue anything that you put your mind to
That's where I'm trying to do with art
Look back at me
Perfect, gotta Photoshop your friend out
(claps)
Brooke: Thanks guys
Dolly Avenue: Woooo
Thanks for waiting
La la la laa
Do you believe that money defines yourself or or others?
Yes
Money is part of what turns you into who you are
Um, in almost every person that I've ever met
Like I wish it were different
I don't think money defines you, I think your character defines you, I think how you treat people defines you
And also how you treat yourself defines you
It's kind of ingrained in us, right
money is quite literally how much you are worth ... (laughs) ... no matter how you try to spin it like there is a number
And I'm sure to some degree we all say that it doesn't— like money can't buy happiness
All right, but a lack of money can lose you some happiness ... (laughs)
Are you happy?
I think I'm happy. I wake up and
look forward to my day
Could I be happier? Yes, absolutely. Like it's not in my nature to pin a point. What would make me happier?
I think everybody wants to strive for more
I think I'm happy in terms of I'm making art and I'm getting paid for it.
I didn't really have anything and I was happy so because of that at the end of a day, I don't really
feel like
hmm...what's the question?
So, what's your day looking like?
If you could do the math in your head?
$400 a day every day. How much  should I spend?
48 bucks plus the 600 from this morning puts us at 650 dollars -ish
So minus $250.
How do you feel about that day?
Quinn: You know besides the car it was pretty good ... (laughs)
(singing) No freedom caged bird
How much money did you make today on that shoot?
Well for the most part, the three hours I made four hundred and she paid for the
studio with just 80 dollars. We're still deciding
moving forward with the image cost
How is it?
It's really good
(singing) Heard you're scared of the downside
I know the darkness can keep you in
Sometimes the doubt of the blurred lines
can keep the
sunlight from creeping in
From creeping in